you
imagine this shifting gears and moving
out of your house to live in a van
believe it or not this is becoming a new
trend with more people adopting a
freewheeling lifestyle I decided to try
it out in California's high desert where
I met a man named Bob Wells he's a
former grocery store clerk who's become
a guru of life on the road what do you
do
hundred miles from nowhere car breaks
down you're in your home you pull over
and you make dinner I think the average
person might come in to a van like this
and think it's a little cramped I think
anybody in the right mind would say this
is a little crap I sleep in here and I
live out there you have enough money at
this point you could go live in a home I
could live at home but why would I
torture myself
[Laughter]
this beauty is our minivan where we have
spent the past two nights it is a
perfect balance between comfort and
freedom bob says and so I can give you
the tour we sleep here that's the
bedroom we put our toiletries here
that's in effect the bathroom you can
see some notebooks up front that's the
office we've got food in the tents over
here and the best part the backyard okay
you can watch my entire journey the van
live this weekend on CBS Sunday morning
I learned a lot and the the biggest
thing is pay your rent